joining us right now here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is one of
our favorites he's a pro football hall
of fame head coach and also a member of
nbc sports just like us from sunday
night football football night in america
tony dungy how are you tony dungy
i'm well rich how are you i'm doing fine
better for talking to you and i truly
mean that
well you're doing fine too since your
wolverines uh are rolling right now well
tony uh i've been chest out uh quite a
bit um
i have been talking i've been writing a
ton of checks that iowa can return to
sender uh on saturday but i am i'm over
the moon right now tony no i'll tell you
what they're playing well
well they're playing old school football
aren't they you know just like just like
john's doing i guess for the ravens that
we saw on sunday night you know they're
they're they're 41 runs i mean my gosh
that's that's what we call commitment
to that running and not in in 2021 we we
don't see that all the time it's spread
them out you know throw
be electric uh but to play old school
run and tough inside football it was it
was kind of a throwback it was what do
you think of the uh
situation that unfolded in college
football this week where lincoln riley
and brian kelly leave oklahoma and notre
dame for
much greener financial pastors and
technically maybe even
coaching pastors but um being done right
at the outset of a college football
playoff season that notre dame's right
in the middle of right now tony it's uh
a little surprising in oklahoma you know
maybe a little bit farther out of it but
they
are in the same boat too you're
preparing for a bowl game
the coaches are out recruiting uh brian
kelly was in california i guess
recruiting someone you're talking to
somebody about coming to notre dame and
why it's the the best place in the world
to come and then in 30 minutes as these
coaches say hey i had one conversation
and all of a sudden i'm in uh at usc or
i'm at lsu
it's it's
it's the way things are uh you know and
everything's a business but it's just
well you feel badly for the kids you
know you feel badly for guys who got
recruited thinking they're going to play
for coach
and uh the coach has done everything he
can to
to sell them and then
it is not there and and it is it's our
system
and you can't begrudge people of that
but it is disappointing well i mean uh
were you
reached out to tony because i mean i
know that tomlin was on a wish list for
usc and if people are taking shooting
their shot with time no i'm serious if
they're if they're shooting their shot
you're like the ultimate shoot your shot
let's see if they'll say no
guy to the i i think most people now
understand that that i've been retired
for 13 years i would have been flattered
but no i would not reach out to uh but i
i guess
with the money that they're they're
talking about you would at least have to
think about it i'd still say no but i
wouldn't say no uh right as soon as i
answer the phone and when they're
talking about 100 million dollars you
have to think about it and then say no
but you'd you'd have you'd have hung up
the phone and thought about it right is
what you're saying yeah yeah yeah well i
bet so but some of the it is crazy uh
some the money that's involved and and
uh just the fact that
gosh what was i reading at lsu that that
x number professors and the top people
on campus 25 or 30 of them don't make
what they're going to pay the the head
football coach um that's where we are
and the head football coach is brings
more notoriety and more attention to the
school and increases donors and that
type of thing so
uh it's supply and demand i guess what
do you think these contracts like the
one for instance that's rumored to be
lincoln riley's where houses are bought
above market value private jets are
afforded to uh his family how do you
think that lands with professional nfl
head coaches do you think that that
gives an idea maybe a little bit well
and eventually when they they do
seriously start coming after the mike
tomlins and
sean payton's and people like that then
it is going to have a rollover effect
into the nfl where the nfl
owners may say now well i'm not doing
that but you know you lose a great coach
you know you lose a
someone
um
you'll have to think about it and then
now an nfl coach i've always
signed up for a long term and get to
security but maybe i want to be on a
one-year two-year deal if i can get a
college to throw 15 million at me and
then i can go back to my owner and say
do you really want me to stay um i i
think it is going to have some some
ramifications right i mean certainly
since you know the college schemes have
now bled into the pros maybe the college
contracts
we'll have to see you know we'll have to
see it tony dungy here on the rich eisen
show your team that you think is best
that you've seen uh with your own two
eyes either
sitting there in the studio or getting
out to a game tony through the first 12
weeks of the nfl season is which which
one do you think you know it's it's
funny i i said uh in september that it
would probably be november 1st just
because of the way things have gone with
off-season programs being cut short
covered nobody playing in the preseason
i just didn't see that consistency in
september and october and i i thought by
november 1 i would kind of know who the
top five or six teams are
but i have to say i really don't um you
know baltimore is playing great they
they go to miami and get
throttled by the dolphins who had only
won one game at the time and you know
tennessee was playing great they lose
a big part of their offense but um
they're they're struggling the last two
weeks and we've just seen it over and
over and over again arizona maybe is
playing the the best and most consistent
um you know but they had a game where
they lost to carolina so
it's just i'm not sure who's going to be
hot and stay hot through december the
playoffs new england is probably playing
the most consistent football of anybody
right now i was gonna say that team tony
because uh in terms of right now as you
pointed out now that it's funny you said
you'd give yourself to november first
here we are just after december 1st and
we still kind of are shrugging about it
right now is that
in terms of
knowing what a team can do and then that
team shows up each week
right it shows up each week physically
mentally uh schematically
uh
new england is that team right now that
you know who you are you know what they
are and they show up they are
they're not gonna be flashy uh but
they're gonna do their job and do their
thing every week you're gonna have to
beat them they're not gonna beat
themselves and they're going to play as
close to their max as
uh as they can every week and that
that's what you're going to ask for um
you know my heart is with the the
indianapolis colts and i see them get a
two-score lead on baltimore and lose the
game and get a two-score lead on tampa
and lose the game and
they're you know for 20 minutes
at a time they're as good as anybody in
the league but they've got some losses
you know that
they're hard to explain so can can we
get that team to show up for 60 minutes
if you do they're as good as anybody
tony dungy here on the rich eisen show
we just saw on nbc on sunday night the
cleveland browns they're six and six on
a bye week sitting at home right now
what is your sense of what is going on
with that offense the passing game and
the conversation that's being had
surrounding baker mayfield what is your
general sense of what you saw sunday
night and how indicative that is of
baker mayfield's fit
in cleveland
well two things we have to understand
about baker number one he's hurt
okay and he's not a hundred percent he's
out there playing which i admire and i
give him credit for and number two
if you look at cleveland last year when
he played so well and he did play well
they had this running game going and
they ran and they threw play-action
passes they made you defend certain
things and they were in a rhythm well
nick chubb you know goes out with covid
kareem hunt is
on the ir for a little bit their running
game is not the same they're not built
to just drop back and throw or throw
35 40 times a game and have the
quarterback
be spectacular that's not who they are
and i think coming down the stretch and
i think after this buy baker will be a
little bit healthier the runners will be
healthier uh the losing the one
offensive tackle really hurts but
they're going to get back to their
identity of who they are and he's going
to throw the ball more effectively
in in december um you know people want
him to be
something that he's not um you know you
look at ryan tannehill right now ryan
tannehill played great for all of last
year and most of this year and even a
game or two after derrick henry went out
he played great but now all of a sudden
it's not the same and you're seeing more
coverages different kind of coverages
you don't have that you know you get in
the red zone and he never threw
interceptions to turn the ball over
because everybody had to play derrick
henry and that makes it easier for you
now they've got to find different things
i think cleveland's the same way they'll
get back to to who they are and they'll
get chubb and hunt rolling and you're
going to see some good baker mayfield in
december well i guess the issue for
mayfield as well that i've mentioned
here many times tony i want to bounce
off you is is the fact that he's a
number one overall pick and you've got
two guys in the draft um josh allen in
particular not lamar who can just do it
without the run game they don't need the
run game as a matter of fact maybe
they're the run game that's not baker
they're also the run game they don't
need the run game they can just do it
and that complementary football you can
have a championship quarterback be a a
complimentary football team if you're
mac jones drafted in the middle of the
first round or tom brady right if you're
199th overall and he's grown onto
obviously somebody who doesn't require a
complimentary football day in and down
he's been that for decades but is is
baker mayfield a championship
quarterback if he's required to have a
complimentary football approach
you know it depends on how how the team
is built
and that that's what people don't always
understand you know you can build a team
to revolve around the quarterback or you
can build a team that that's gonna win
and and the quarterbacks are part of it
and
um you know i don't know is baker
mayfield can he there's probably only
two or three quarterbacks playing right
now uh maybe aaron rodgers um
you know we we saw tom brady when the
team kind of struggled in 2019 and
everybody oh you know what's wrong with
tom brady maybe we're coming to the end
well we weren't coming to the end the
team just wasn't
what it had been and they were missing
some cogs the way they were constructed
um
you know and and and i think that's
where cleveland is cleveland is not a
team with dynamic wide receivers and a
passing game that's just going to go out
and light it up every week um
no matter who's there and we've seen
aaron rodgers do that we've seen him
with devonta adams out and still throw
to other guys and and be great because
that's how they're constructed they're
built around aaron rodgers but
um you know not everybody's like that so
do you think maybe in last one for you
on this that the browns aren't properly
constructed around
baker because i mean
i think they are who they are they're
built for what kevin stefanski wants he
wants to be a dominant running team he
wants to be very physical uh he wants
wide receivers who block and he wants to
win
uh the way you're gonna have to win in
cleveland you know in in
the wintertime
and i think that's what he's
constructing now
um you know when all those elements
aren't there and they aren't running the
ball dominant um you know can baker win
games for them by himself
probably not uh
and and probably not at this point but
that that's okay um you know
that's
that that's who they are
have you watched the manning cast yet
tony have you watched any of these i
haven't watched parts of it uh my wife
actually likes to watch
the regular broadcast better okay uh
because she wants to know what down and
distance it is and how much time is left
in the game
and sometimes you don't get that on the
mannycatch so she's a traditionalist but
so
okay what do you think of peyton's uh uh
broadcasting skills what do you think so
far well i i think it's a definitely a
different style that people gravitate to
peyton could be an exceptional color
commentator uh just on a regular
broadcast he can certainly do this um
he he can do it kind of any way you want
i i think this really plays to a lot of
people uh fans like me who i i can watch
the game and see what's happening in the
background and listen to him and the
guests and get entertained and get
information and still watch the game uh
i think it's uh it plays to a niche of
people but i think he's really good at
it yeah i know but if he did a
traditional broadcast tony we wouldn't
be able to watch him eat during it you
know i mean like
yeah
i'm sure you've seen payton eat before i
haven't you know what i mean like so
you know though to me it really does it
seems it seemed like a we're in how we
were 15 years ago watching uh film in in
the complex and and you know hey he's
pointing out things and we're talking
about different things that are going on
it's just like watching tape with them
and that's a pretty cool feeling i would
think for the general audience it sure
is to me too tony and the fact that i
just love watching him and eli too but
peyton in particular he gets
particularly irked by bad football
terrible
you know what and i i can i can
sympathize with him because i sit in our
viewing room the same way uh i'm sitting
up there with drew brees i used to sit
there with rodney harrison yeah and
you've watched things happen and you say
certainly they had to cover that what
was this running back thank you how
could you run out of bounds with a
minute 20 seconds left when you're ahead
how could you that that just can't
happen right and it it it does and then
i feel like that old man is telling
people to get off the lawn you know and
i
well the funny thing is i used to watch
games with dion and dion would scream at
anybody who made a bad mistake he would
scream at the screen cut him he said if
i was coaching i would cut him before
coming back and now look who's the swac
coach of the year i don't know i know
it's how about so funny you know it is
so funny you get so mesmerized by
um just
you know
not feeling
like that should happen right and when
it does happen it just kills you as a as
a former player as a former coach and
then you realize hey you know what
everybody's out there trying nobody
wants to make mistakes
um
but but but they happen and the more you
can come that's why i admire new england
so much they they work on that they cut
out those
bad plays and they make people beat them
and if you do that you're going to win a
ton of games tony dungy thanks for the
time you take care let's talk down the
line and obviously in advance i'll ask
you on the air i'd love to see you in
person when you're out here for the
super bowl for super bowl 56. we'll see
you guys oh we got to do it we got to do
it i'd love to you'll be well tony dungy
you take care of yourself that's tony
dungy everybody hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here